("Monday To Monday" by Saba)
- Saba, I've been telling you.
Yo, what's up Vayner Nation?
Driving back to
the city right now.
This is a fun DailyVee.
Want to make it
a little collaboration
with me and you guys.
Obviously, holiday weekend.
Got some family time in and
really debating if I really
actually want to do seven
days a week of DailyVee.
Obviously the #BizDevSundays
are good but like in a classic
four day weekend like this
just four selfie phone vlogs.
I'm not sure if that's
bringing you the most value.
So I want to make this a
special feedback DailyVee.
I'm leaning towards actually
not doing every weekend.
Obviously some weekends
going to Super Bowl,
Jordan and going to
different things.
Maybe there's some reason
for DRock or Tyler or others,
ooh I'm excited Tyler's gonna
be filming me this whole week.
- [Jordan] Yeah.
- To come, obviously
South-by is coming up, do that.
Cannes, we'll do that.
But I'm not sure I want
to do a every weekend.
Obviously, I'm excited about the
daily commitment but I think one
of the things I'm most proud
of is I change my mind like you
know, to me, you know changing
your mind is such an important
part of entrepreneurship.
Such a big part of my strategy.
I don't fall in
love with anything.
Obviously, keeping your word
is different than changing your
strategy or mind and so
I'm always balancing that.
Please don't get those
two things confused.
But for me here, I think it's
important for me to bring value
in the vlog form.
I love the idea of
seven days a week.
It's why I
created #BizDevSunday.
I thought that would
take care of the that day.
I'm thrilled to keep
going and doing it.
I really am.
I guess I'm looking for
permission from you guys
who I adore so much,
how do you like these two,
three, four, five, six
minute phone very kind of raw.
It's a different look.
You know, Jordan you
get a lot of face time.
You're probably sad.
(Jordan laughs)
Anyway, would
love your feedback.
Would love to see
what you guys think
about the seven
day a week thing.
What should I do?
What's your thoughts?
Are there any
other random thoughts?
Leave a comment.
Maybe Saturday's we take a bunch
of highlight videos from fans
and give them shout outs.
There's a lot we can do.
Would love to get
your two cents.
Debating the format.
Five days a week, firm.
Done, locked in.
Randoms weekends
when there's cool stuff.
Super Bowl, Sundance,
Cannes, locked in firm.
But what about just kind
of those everyday weekends.
Is the perspective from
the phone quick little two,
("Maui Moon" By Kellen Nguyen)
#BizDevSundays little
themes like that good enough?
Or should we stick to
kind of longer form stuff
and take the weekends off?
Would love your two cents.
Leave three if you want.
Much love.
three, four minute
rants, Facebook Lives,